اذا كنت تبكي على متن الطائره اثناء رحلتك
من مكان لاخر فالامر ربما ليس له علاقه
مباشره بالمشاعر تخيل بالفعل يا راويه
خاصه اذا علمنا ان هناك سبب غريب لهذا
البكاء توضحوه خبيره السفر برا
ون مشاهده فيلم
سببا مباشرا وربما لا يكون سببا في الامر
اساسا خبيره السفر تؤكد ان الطائرات تسبب
جفاف العيون ما يحفز الدماغ على ارسال
اشارات الى مجاري الدمع لتعمل على ترطيب
العين وهو ما يسبب هذا البكاء المفاجئ
والصادم احيانا
لا بس بالبيت والله
يعني
دخلت ممر السعاده فانسى تكون اه مبسوطه
وفعلا استغربت جدا كنت عم بتفرج على متن
طائره على فيلم سندريلا قصه كلنا بنعرفها
انه احنا اطفال
اجهزت بالبكاء بطريقه غريبه لدرجه كل
المسافرين اللي جنبي انتبهوا علي وفكروا
انه انا بعاني من مشاكل شخصيه ويجيبوا لي
محارم طلع الطائره لا عندك
مشاعر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات